it's the morning after I feel like
[ __ ] death we're gonna be taking
monitor drinks after a series of tests
one dancing to conversation three field
sobriety tests once we finish one round
of tests we come back we take another
drink together okay then we keep going
through the test yep until we blow a
point oh eight how about you guys
I'd actually drink like a couple beers a
night casually with dinner and I
normally on an average party night top
out between 8 and 11 drinks a couple of
beers isn't casual to me typical night I
dream one or two glasses of white wine
with my life so you drink every night
drink every night I drink every night
and occasionally during the morning
sometimes when I got work early my
drinking tolerance interval I like
drinking I'm just not very good at
clothes will be drinker and I'm
definitely a lightweight at five drinks
and I'm going to get very very drunk
I think it'll take me three drinks I'm
gonna just say five at the rate we're
drinking quickly to two fields right
around number one one shot of whiskey
and one can of beer
so much I think the assumption is that
you're gonna dance worse as you get
drunker but keep them Zach who cannot
dance very well dance terribly sober
especially next to a hot girl oh god I
have a wife please don't do this to me
Lowe's your eyes touch your nose with
that finger done I'm gonna come to each
one of you and I want you to follow my
finger
okay I'm like a tightrope walker I would
never walk like that I'm just saying
this is not a thing that people do the
toe your toes to your heels
Wow I think I'm probably at 0.05 point a
1.19 that was way less than we thought
it would go - I'm gonna say 0.04 I feel
kind of tipsy 0.017 I'm less strength
Enki so I'm just gonna crisis right and
say point zero one six because I think I
have the highest all right one zero one
six no way get the [ __ ] out based on
them I can't imagine that point away
like no you're light weight you're
actually I'm more affected by alcohol by
the same amount more shots daddy
so we're basically doing one side of
tequila and we're gonna sip on a cup of
wine why are we mixing that's not a good
night because this is a Tuesday we have
work tomorrow we're at or just spilled
all your tequila
I hate it tastes like water
hey give me another so bad let's do
another one more all right yes to that
as they got drunker they've danced
better
do you see mad at Ned because use
rowdiest
[ __ ] and like turned us in the little
frat boys they're not legally drunk
until actually way later than we thought
feel like I wouldn't drive I would leave
my car wherever it was and take the cab
with my wife back home
oh I jumped high I'm drunker than these
two physically but I'm acting the most
sober point zero nine five about 1215
minutes ago I have not had a drink since
point zero six seven yeah so you could
like leave a place at point o six but
you could totally be driving at 0.09 and
you would think you are okay
vodka shots too drunk I feel a hammer
John right now I would definitely drive
I don't feel drunk at all am I drunk yes
do I hate vodka absolutely I already
dance [ __ ] but dancing no I'm
over point of late at this point I just
wanna go home when I heard but thought
right well will I I'm Kendall supervisor
which means that this may be an HR
violation why they always castle
what happens interns assigned on the try
guys shoot keith's the guy you bring to
a party to have fun point one zero
different my I didn't realize how many
drinks it took to get 2.08 or how time
and how you metabolize the booze like
just sitting you could get drunker it's
the guy you lose cuz he got into a fight
hey 0.087 you so drunk I can get just as
crazy you have just as much fun
whether I'm drunk or I'm sober Jean is
the kind of guy you go to a party with
but you don't go home once you're mine
cause I still do not feel that drunk you
don't necessarily have a lower blood
alcohol content level because you can
drink more because you don't feel as
drunk you will still be arrested that is
the guy you bring to party if you want
to leave early point one to that one
more is that more or less than before to
me this is proved proven people get
drunk because point oh eight is the
number it doesn't mean that magically
you're flying below that like I
definitely would not have driven I feel
terrible I hated this experience but
ride together try together try guys for
life I woke up at 5 in a lot of pain I'm
here walking my dogs they'll toll if I'm
dehydrated headache nauseous by pubes
I feel pretty good ready to get some
breakfast [ __ ] drinking I'm done